welcome back to Pierce Morgan uncensored
me Rosanna Lockwood in the chair tonight
I'm joined by the pack in the studio the
Monday night pack associate editor of
the mirror Kevin McGuire talk TV
contributor Esther Krakow and socialist
and author Grace Blakely rejoins us all
of you it's been an interesting show so
far I think it's fair to say women have
been in charge um and even Kevin O'Leary
was a pussycat great I was so surprised
I was really ready to have a fight with
my my voice completely gone but I didn't
need to no let's stay on the topics
regarding uh women and men shall we
because we talked to you about this
before the break Andrew Tate that uh
very controversial male has made
comments about Amanda Holden um the much
loved celebrity who was posed in a
bikini posted these photos of himself on
holiday she's 52 years old I'm going to
say she looks absolutely incredible if
she wants to post a photo of herself in
a bikini and I'm not even gonna say if
her husband approves because who cares
about that but if she wants to do it
that's what she's chosen to do Andrew
Tate tweeted a reply to that saying
quote you're a wife and a mother and you
are far past a teenager there is no need
for this post
um I would argue there is no need for
that comment uh but of course it's
Andrew Tate we're talking about here uh
Kevin no surprises no well look Amanda
Holden go on holiday a post a photograph
he's under house arrest and can't go on
holiday maybe he's just jealous isn't it
I mean look he's a vile horrible book I
didn't actually think about that
actually it is violent horrible and
there we are if you post a picture of
yourself you're going to get some
comments flat that's coming back yeah
but of course look he's he is just fine
he's just a misogynist that's uh it like
I think in mind this problem is she does
look great but you know she also has uh
how do I put this nice issues a little
more plastic than Tupperware that being
said
that being said when you put when you
put post pictures like that of yourself
online you will get comments it's the
truth now I have no problem with her
posting that because again she looks she
looks better than I do arguably her body
is she's far more dismissed with her
diet and physically but listen this is
hard for the course I think she should
be concerned about being able to move
parts of her face than than part of a
very tight talk no no shame in the
surgery no Shameless
it's literally like I feel like other
things the goal is not to look crazy I
have no problem with with doing
enhancing tucking nipping you don't want
to look crazy when you can't move your
face you look crazy so that's that's
what I'll say there but look her body
looks fantastic I mean she looks great
like um like her body yeah neck down
yeah she looks great and I agree
agitated he's an awful man and we
shouldn't really be you know that women
get a lot of
um a lot of comments about their
physical appearance and that's often why
they feel the need and the pressure to
go onto the knife to have these
procedures in order to look and feel
young and feel accepted I think if
there's people going out there and
sharing pictures of their body with all
of their flaws and everything out to see
we should be encouraging that and yeah
of course you're going to get negative
comments because some people are already
supporting one another I don't think the
response to insecurity would be to seek
validation online I understand that
there is pressure for women to look a
certain way but I do think it's a
testament to this interaction isn't it
it's about your relationship with
yourself you shouldn't value strangers
comments on that that shouldn't be a
barometer no but we should be able to
say like look here's an example of a
woman showing her body in a way that is
proud and like she's happy with it and
like we should be happy yeah
I just say uh the man under house arrest
doesn't speak for the majority
of the way you're not under house arrest
no no I'm free
let's turn the considerable brains in
this studio to matters a little bit more
serious uh than just talking about
bodies we can talk about body parts all
day I know you know but let's talk about
another story that headlined a lot of
the newspapers today it's regarding this
British man David Hunter uh he was freed
in Cyprus after being sentenced for
manslaughter he um it killed his wife 76
years old he had already spent 19 months
in custody it's an absolutely tragic
story this uh his wife Janice Hunter 74
died of asphyxiation at their retirement
home in Cyprus back in December 2021 now
he wasn't sentenced on murder so no Pro
meditation is what the court decided and
they decided to release him basically on
compassionate grounds here the judge in
Cyprus actually talking about the fact
that love played such a huge part in
this
um Janice had a rare type of blood
cancer and was in a lot of pain and it
obviously brings to mind this
complicated debate about euthanasia
Cyprus will remind ourselves as a Greek
Orthodox country which makes this
incredible be tough to consider and very
different from the considerations we
have here in the UK but Kevin I mean
do you think this will reignite debates
about assisted dying because in Europe
it is allowed in some countries it is
it's not allowed in the UK it certainly
isn't in Cyprus which is a socially
conservative I think it's a debate we
we do need uh because you sometimes
condemn people to live and they want to
end their life and certainly in the UK
if you've got the money in the
organization you can go to Switzerland
dignitas you're okay your family won't
be prosecuted for taking you out and
bringing you back in fact a friend of
mine went and ended her life because she
didn't want the grisly end with Ms that
was ahead of her and those who returned
who had taken her there was no action
taken against him but I think we've just
got to address it because yeah because
if you love somebody and they're asking
you to help them end their suffering and
their Agony it must it must be an awful
dilemma but but you will want to help
them and you will want to carry out
their wishes I think the thing is we do
have this conversation regularly in the
UK about euthanasia which I think is a
good thing obviously you don't want the
extreme of what's going on in Canada for
instance where you could argue that
people are being giving euthanasia as an
option too easily I think the issue here
is
um obviously the court has decided that
it wasn't murder premeditated murder was
manslaughter
um but when you're talking about it in
the context of euthanasia the issue is
when when you ask for to be to to die to
have for assisted suicide um in
countries that allow this you know there
is a threshold you must meet to be sure
that you have sound mind now obviously
the person
um that would testify to this I don't
know if she left a letter or anything
like that it's not alive to be assessed
by someone other than the person who's
trying to get off
um this charge of murder so I think
that's the issue here is the fact that
he said obviously she wanted it but you
know it's not just the fact that she
wanted it has it been it has it been
sustained that she was of sound mind to
say that she wanted it this is why you
know this often happens with things that
people need or want which are made
illegal it's the the boundary between
something that's regulated and
accessible versus something that's
illegal
um becomes you know the problem because
if you had a system in which there was a
sister dying that was regulated that you
were made sure that for example people
weren't being put under pressure by
their families for inheritance or
interpression by medical
um you know associations or if they have
all their mental faculties exactly it's
really difficult you know you have a
system which is it's regulated if you
just basically say people are allowed to
kill people when they are asked to do so
that's obviously a feasible framework
when my dad was on the way out I wished
we could have helped him three months
out if it had been a dog or a cat we
wouldn't have allowed him to suffer the
way he had to yeah
fundamentally holds different value to a
human being like human life is more
valuable than a chicken
fundamentally that is why we shouldn't
have allowed him to Suffer Well yeah I
understand that I think in this
particular case it's more of just the
fact that the person who would testify
to her own sound mind is no longer here
and there's a vested interest for this
man to not be it's impossible
is it is it a Hallmark of civilized it's
like I'm not saying that the countries
that don't have this in place are not
civilized but is it a debate that should
be had I think it is because yeah I mean
this you know what is the difference
between a cat and a dog and a person
like we have decision making
capabilities and you know a conscious
understanding of our own suffering not
just the suffering itself but the fact
that we are likely to continue to
experience it which is what often makes
things so terrible people we brought
that back to a vaguely serious
conversation I'm very impressed Grace
Esther Kevin thank you very much for
joining me